um
you know what i really like when two
mega stars
interview each other you know it's it's
like
it's crazy like the meetings of the mind
like you know like
one of those like super bands and stuff
you do realize you have pete davidson on
the screen
that's pete davis yeah oh my god
i thought it was just a butthole with
teeth yeah i'm really sorry
well here we have uh glenn close is
interviewing pete davidson
and he's talking about his bipolar
disorder oh of course he is
i was always just so confused all the
time and just like
thought something was wrong pete
davidson is opening up about his mental
health
oh my god that's all he does but that's
all he does
it's it's like stop stop pretending like
he's been this elusive creature that
oh i don't like to talk about my
personal stuff man like that's all he
talks about
this you might as well write an article
and go uh we got a random white girl to
open up about her mental illness
like well yeah it's literally all you
have to do is sit down next to a white
girl and they'll be like i have bipolar
and i just and they say i'm really addy
and i have ocd
like it's all he talks about he's an
uninteresting white woman
but that's a really good point like who
i'm not even saying you know we finally
got him to open up about his
right i'm not i'm not saying like you
know imagine you got like a you know
someone a a
big star on like bill murray comes on
you know i've been suffering
from depression for years yeah you go
wow like that's that's a guy that never
opens up about things you're glad why
don't you just [ __ ] deal why don't
you just [ __ ] deal with it
the same way robin williams did [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh here i i have the interview without
the guy interjecting in the middle so
let's just pull that up
pete david's close obviously and you're
pete
davidson yeah you were unfortunate
unfortunately david davidson
is that how you say it the imagination
and it's that's
oh so they did pardon julian but here we
are i
the thing that i also and maybe we're
gonna veer all over the place but
i find stand-up comedy one of the most
terrifying propositions i could think of
so i want to ask you about that the way
pete davidson does it
well glenn it's actually really easy
what you do is you have everybody
signing nda
saying they're not allowed to talk about
anything or you'll sue them out of
existence
that's what i do anyway you should try
that which
where do you think it's courageous and
where it comes from because i find
it's courageous right doing stand-up is
courageous
it's basically like being a frontline
worker
is it really they're heroes i mean the
people who work at walmart are heroes
now that i guess we can give stand-up
comics
the hero status right everybody's a hero
now the word's worthless anyway it is
like frontline workers because both of
them don't really ever see their kids so
yeah that
sounds about right but like seriously if
i got to drive past one more jiffy lube
or tire kingdom that says heroes work
here i'm going to slit my wrist
no puerto ricans work there okay
i find it astounding um
how you you create does she does glenn
close have a receding hairline
first of all it's julian assange show
some respect and just be grateful that
he's out
you're right material out of your own
life and you have the courage to get up
there and talk about is glenn close to
the original handsome woman
yes she was one of them she's a handsome
woman
well first i think we would all love to
see glenn close to stand up uh that
would be incredible
we'd all like to see pete davidson get
something better than a 360p
[ __ ] webcam what do these people do
in this industry now besides just
lie about how exciting and great
everything is
right like do they do anything else no
like i would love to see their standoff
playing well i think everybody would
love to do yeah i watch her bomb
how horrendously
um i i think it is uh
there's obviously tons of more uh
courageous jobs but i do think it is
kind of courageous to get on stage
in front of people because it is
terrifying the reason why i think i was
able to do it is because like uh
a thing happened to me when i was really
young like
we lost my dad so i was just whoa whoa
oh boy this first
look kid you act like you're the only
one who ever lost a father
my dad died too bro a 911.
everybody in new york is nah he died
like six years ago he was really old
but the point is wait a second
this is the first time hearing of pete
davidson's dad dying is that holding us
about is that all that's left in new
york is people crying about their dead
dads
like they really take the nickname
gotham seriously
seriously when i was 16
i i always wanted to try it because uh
it was like what got me by eddie murphy
and
uh chappelle and gilbert and
um people like mullany and
uh it was just such a great escape and
my friends were like you should do it
and i was like
uh they were like what's the worst thing
that could happen and i was like oh
you're right the worst you could get
famous and then we'd never get rid of
you that would be
that's pretty that's the worst case
scenario in my mind very scary
pretty much already happened that's so
[ __ ] funny i know a guy that was in
that
ho billy elegy or that he was an extra
in that movie and he wouldn't shut up
about it
and he's one of those guys that like
he's been doing stand-up forever he's
been doing he's been doing he's chasing
the dream the same way
we all did at some point and uh
he's one of those guys that like lives
like he he's
he moved from florida because he
couldn't afford to live in florida which
like how do you not afford to live in
florida
and then like this guy's like always
talking about like
the business and the craft and stuff but
like this was his big moment was like
he was like look i i got to see a movie
that i was in
and it's like yeah but like on netflix
it's not like you went to a movie
theater and you were like oh look at me
on the big screen
and it's like he's one of those many
people that you see that are like yeah
bro i'm just out there
you know i'm on the road doing gigs
living the dream but they live out of
their car and they have like no money on
them and you're like
that sounds terrible that sounds like a
terrible way to live
i was in a movie though it's like yeah
you were in the background pouring a cup
of coffee it wasn't like
you know nobody went oh [ __ ] that guy
he's the next big thing
of abu abuse substance abuse and
physical abuse is
passed down to the next generation
unless it's taken care of
do you think your dead dad was a drunk
pete do you think
do you think you did that at a drug
problem
do you think maybe that's why he didn't
make it out of the tower in time
because he was so hungover did he have a
bunch of terrible tattoos done by his
buddy in his basement
now that would be a funny interview hey
dad was your dad
hey pete was your dad a smoker was he
smoker and a drinker because it's
probably why i couldn't get down the
stairs so
watch this because the beauty about
hollywood is these people are so
fake that he'd have to sit there and be
nice to glenn close that's
that would be the best part of it just
watching her turn the screws on
you know i mean a lot of it is ptsd and
and if you don't take care of ptsd it
just gets worse and worse and worse
and it will keep affecting you don't you
love listening to millionaires talking
about how they have ptsd
it's awesome it's [ __ ] awesome no one
else on the set of uh
stop it probably an affect to all the
people around you
this looks terrible which one's going
close in this scene this looks terrible
right
of course it's of course it's terrible
it's like you know it's funny it's like
you when you have like these hollywood
elites try to write like
hillbillies it never feels right like
you could always feel when a show is
well written or well done and they have
a like
um they have roots in the area that
they're writing about like
when somebody like lives in in whatever
florida panhandle they want to make a
florida panhandle movie
that's the best guy for a boy these
hollywood things like families oh my god
we live in the woods
where all hills have eyes people and
it's like they're not though they're
actually
there are hills have ice people in
chicago of course
but you know there's also tons of people
that live there
because they work at the local jail or
because they work at you know what i
mean like there's jobs up there they
might be involved in in
in some sort of uh manufacturing
business but like they just treat it
like
ah we're all out they and it's like
they're not all like that though there's
a lot of people that just are like yeah
hi i live in the florida panhandle
so i would move but you know i work at
florida state prison and it's right
there and
i mean what am i going to commute from
orlando come on but these people just
they are so stop trying to stop trying
to like
uh stop trying to write things about
hillbilly people you're not good at it
it's terrible i thought
something was wrong and didn't know how
to deal with it and then like
when somebody finally tells you that
the weight of the world just feels
lifted off your shoulders you just feel
you didn't realize the movie was made by
the book uh by a book of a guy that came
from that environment yes have you read
the book
uh because if you've read the book he
doesn't make them look like backwards
hillbilly [ __ ] water people
because it's based on a book doesn't
mean that they don't take creative
license with it and
execute it poorly that's executed poorly
though the book was actually an
uplifting story about
a dude that came out of a really bad
environment and he made it but
they're does ron howard direct this
movie they're making it this cartoonish
this is cartoonish well i've dip in my
mouth not crazy
i'm a crazy shower and okay granted most
of those people are crazy and probably
have dip in their mouth fine
but like you know find a respectable way
to portray it
so much better so i hope she uh feels
that way as well um
i i think uh no i thought it was really
spot on just like uh
the way it affects other people is is
what you
really don't think about i think when
you're um
starving for an addiction because it's
just that is the most
important thing at the time is just you
know kind of trying to
get by i have a question pete do you
still smoke weed every day
well yeah but it's medicinal because if
you smoke weed every day i hate to break
it to your pal but you're addicted to
something just a heads up
nah but it's medicinal that's it's okay
okay keep telling yourselves that
it's medicine man really because i don't
recall ever smoking medicine but that's
just
just maybe that's just me it was
it was like beautifully done but also
just so emotional
and um it was it was it was
it was just really an honest depiction
let's talk about king of staten island
and the fact can we not yeah can we not
it's not that can we not
please actually not thank you please
stop pretending like this was a good
movie
thank you it's his only that's literally
why they do it because it's his
only movie to talk about he doesn't have
anything else you know if you if you
were interviewing adam sandler you'd
have a [ __ ]
laundry list of movies you could talk
about
yeah this is funny fergus fergus is
saying uh okay adderall guy that smokes
weed mike's not pretending to be
[ __ ] trying to be clean guy and
trying to get over it seem angry
honestly he owns it hey fergus it seems
like you've been hanging on to that for
a little bit
yeah he he owns it there's a difference
between like you know every day is a
battle than to like yeah i smoke weed
and i drink who gives a [ __ ] by the way
i love these
to do that they'll be like yeah man
we're cool like we're totally cool in a
minute you disagree with them yeah you
[ __ ] out of role addict
piece of [ __ ] and you're like whoa hey
sounds like you
uh are being very emotional about a guy
that makes [ __ ] jokes on the internet
maybe he stopped getting so emotionally
involved with a fat
comedian from youtube steve buscemi's in
this movie
like he was in kingston first of all the
story oh that's right that's right he
played one of the 911
yeah steve buscemi has to remind us
every couple of years that he was a
firefighter like we get it
he's so wonderful and your character is
so wonderful in it
are the other characters that are in the
king of staten island people that
were actually in your childhood or in
your growing up there and my crew
yeah and your crew the friends that i
had
in the movie were pretty much spot on
with the ones
i had in real life the firemen that all
my dad's friends
actually one of the actors was one of my
dad's real friends and
he always wanted to be an actor so it
was it was really cool to have him on
set
and also like if you know staten island
there's this
scene where we're all in a basement and
some guy just comes to the window asking
for like pills
it's it's very staten island that's
that's
pretty much how how it rolls down here
uh
it's we we don't we do not get a great
rap you must have
a great mom i'm a veteran yeah you live
here
this isn't me making the joke like
people do he does literally live in her
basement
that's not a made-up thing very very
lucky boy my mom
a single mom raised me and my sister by
herself
had three jobs still takes care of
us she's i'm a very very lucky boy
for sure she's the kind of person i'd
love to sit down and
and have you know glenn close wouldn't
make eye contact
with anybody like pete davidson's mother
the only reason she's pretending is
because she's a good actress
and you have him on there's can you
imagine
if [ __ ] glenn closes walking down the
street and she goes hey
uh i'm actually pete's mom and you said
you wanted to talk to me
it was pete exactly that's cool exactly
what would happen well actually
i have to poke some holes in your logic
there royce
um because your entire scenario that you
just dreamed up
um is uh predicated on
glenn cost being caught dead in staten
island which
she would never run into pete davidson's
mother because she'd never take the
ferry
to staten island yeah nobody likes that
other new yorkers don't go there like if
you know somebody that's like hey we're
partying whatever and you're
and you're in the city and they're like
yo come party whatever we're in staten
island
the appropriate response is always yeah
can't you come over here though
because we're in brooklyn and it's way
better can you just come here
i'm not going to staten island cup of
coffee with somebody she must be a very
cool person
and what did she think of
what does she think of king of staten
island she was
she was like petey is it only coming out
on hulu
what do they still have theaters honey
i mean yeah congrat is that like a
youtube channel
or i was gonna tell my friends to see it
but they don't have a hulu subscription
is it on netflix
davidson jesus christ
uh pete davidson really does feel like
one of those
some people become famous because you
know whether you like them or not
because you know they do something and
it's big
is it just me or does pete davidson feel
like one of these
artificially famous people like one of
these things where they've decided that
pete davidson's gonna be famous
yeah like it's it's they've been asked
her turfing him forever
one day they woke up and they just
decided hey guess what pete davidson's
gonna be famous
against every [ __ ] any metric of why
this guy should be famous he's not a
good actor i mean
i mean look at him you know he he's not
really funny
and every time we make fun of pete
davidson and we we clip the stuff
there's always something
he has these droves of [ __ ] usually
women it's not men i'll i'll we'll say
this
the people that defend single mothers
that pete reminds them of the guy that
dumped calm in them and left
that's right that's exactly what it is
pete davidson reminds every single
mother of the guy that left them
right and they're like you leave peter
he's awesome he's awesome and
and you know even if you don't think
he's funny you shouldn't be mean because
he has a mental
disorder yeah and then they always they
always say the things about pete
that women say about like abusive guys
or like dudes that are junkies that you
go like why are you with this guy like
you could do better than this and
they're like
he's trying really hard all right you're
right
they they say that about being there
he's trying really hard and i'm like so
are a lot of people
so are a lot of more deserving people to
be on snl
frankly was
first off very emotional and proud that
i got
to do a job she was just like very
thrilled and
it was just like i i'm very happy that
you get to do something you're
passionate about and then well besides
heroin
because he's really big into that too at
an island
and it's hilarious the way the two of
you talk especially that bit where
you're saying
his picture in the paper looked like
this and your picture so glenn close
watched like clips of it
to make it seem like she watched the
movie and now she's slipping in a
specific reference so it looks like
she's watching
i know that trickling yeah like when
talk show hosts like read the middle of
somebody's book
hey glenn me and him know what you're
doing we see right through we know
exactly exactly this play of course
i love the chapter of your book when you
talk about uh your time
when you were at disney and how much fun
that was
one chapter didn't even read the chapter
you just saw one chapter was called my
time at disney yep
great things when you come zooming on to
a weekend update
you've written that right because it
seems so incredible can you pause
forget about pete for a second i know
what you're gonna do look at everything
else right yeah
look at just how like
clean and sanitized snl looks right
like isn't that it doesn't have that
like go back and watch old snl it had
like a gritty
fun like edgy vibe to it then not quite
ready for prime time players and all
that but like look at how just
the lighting and the smiling black guy
and the
you're right i mean go look up go go
look at back go look back at when norm
was what was weekend update
or it was it was you knew
something you were like oh man what are
these guys going to say they're about to
rip these people apart
and now it's just like i have [ __ ]
orange man huh
orange man bad am i right and it's just
midwest people are stupid compared to us
it feels so sanitized it's gross
yeah that's a good point dave
what's his face so the guy we did the
roast with actually writes all the stuff
for the weekend update yeah dave cyrus
yeah
yeah um i i write all those uh
with my writing partner dave who wrote
uh
okay the king of state island with me
and we just uh we usually just sit in a
room and we
try to make as much fun of it that's
right dave wrote that too
uh i like you dave but jesus me is
possible
and then just like put jokes around
around it but that's
that's my favorite thing to do because
it's just uh well because
no no also getting terrible tattoos
don't forget
on all that makeup and stuff and
sometimes i love it but
the worst thing is like sometimes you're
only in like one thing
and you'll be dressed up like like a
clock
or like i had a dress whoa whoa so he's
pointing out that
even the guy that everyone's pushing
is sometimes shows up and he only does
one thing
like a clock or like i had to dress up
as like count chocula which is a
like a serial mascot we all know what
[ __ ] count chocula is
and you're just stuck in this outfit for
like four hours
in your dressing room just looking at
yourself in the mirror and you're like
what
what am i doing you you look you
honestly look more presentable as count
chocula
then you do normally
scott and you're just stuck in this
outfit for like four hours
in your dressing room just looking at
yourself in the mirror and you're like
what
what am i doing why am i dressed like
count chocolate
it's so crazy is this is it
is it crazy it's your your first movie
for netflix
yes think so yeah were you uh super
pumped about that
are you do you have an opinion between
uh a movie coming out
uh either on netflix or in theaters is
there
is there one yeah look look at her oh
wow
look at her face look at her okay you
gotta watch this
you gotta see that she is not happy she
absolutely like
insulted her in a very amazing way look
at her face watch
do you have an opinion between uh a
movie coming out
uh either on netflix or in theaters is
there
is there one that you'd rather
oh god it's awkward in here
imagine giving all this money to these
people and they're all just like
netflix yep
look let's see look you see that this is
like she did the
this that face is the hollow darkness my
old friend face she's not happy she is
just like i made a huge mistake
displeased
oh boy either or
did you enjoy the the streaming
streaming world
yeah i think um it's it it's interesting
how this whole get ready for these
mental gymnastics that are coming from
playing clothes
more creative freedom you think we're
gonna get that more and more creative oh
i like this okay i like what you're
doing this way okay what are we gonna
get okay more creative freedom yeah
um uh it's a looser atmosphere you know
you can chill
oh oh less pressure to perform
because you have to worry about box
office numbers they have a built-in
audience
yeah who needs an oscar yeah built-in
built-in audience okay let's see
many options we now have that we didn't
have before
i mean it's crazy to think that when i
started
in 1974 uh it was theater tv
or movies right there was no cable
nothing and um
tv was definitely the the poor cousin
a boogie bumper says has has another one
streaming is the future we can't avoid
it
she's gonna say that that's another good
one i think you can almost choose if you
have
the um luxury of choosing how it how
best to tell your story uh do you want
to have a stream
a mini series do you want to do a longer
series you want to do a movie
and you can choose it for how you want
it to impact
people i think the streaming thing is
great because
i mean during covid i have looked at
whole i should have said during covert
[ __ ] i was thinking of it too when i
say netflix
is the fat girl that you're [ __ ]
because your girl left you yeah
got it i've looked at whole series i
never would have done that before
i really miss and i think everybody
misses
going to a theater and getting your
popcorn and your milk duds and and
sitting down and seeing a movie
with hill thank you i'm so glad you
focused on that [ __ ] eats milk though
come on you get mini snickers or m ms
in a community of people and you all
kind of react to it together and that's
an important thing for humans
it is lucky to have the audience that
netflix there it is gives us yes
built-in audience i get one point one
point for me
put it down someone keep score one point
you know millions more people
will see our stories than would have
if it had been well millions more people
are going to look at the trailer that
netflix auto plays and they'll be like
yeah very the same number of people are
going to see your stories
in theaters and i'm really really
grateful
like roy said they're going to see it on
the menu and they're going to go this is
hillbilly allergy clean clothes
yeah i'm not watching that john
mulaney's got a new special
that's exactly what you're gonna do i
have to talk about
you know one of this is one of my
favorite two favorite movies
uh growing up and still it's very
legendary
101 and a hundred into a dalmatian
that's the movie you picked
oh [ __ ] that's the movie you get glenn
close and look i don't really like lynn
close but
you you have to admit storied career
right storied career she's
definitely my top favorite actress from
101 dalmatians ever
oh my god oh my god pete what are you
doing bud
wow
there's so many questions but like what
what made you uh want to want to do that
can i answer
disney gave me a lot of money they
pulled the dump truck up
and just poured money on my front lawn
and i kept
asking them to stop and i wasn't even
definitely saying yes but then they just
they just kept doing it dumping money
and then eventually i went all right all
right all right
bob iger showed up in a ferrari he said
this is yours now and he left
a brink's truck just pulled up to my
house
that role that such an iconic it was
so amazing no no nobody remember okay
i'm sorry
pete nobody remembers the live-action
101 dalmatians and remember the cartoon
i don't and i could say this confidently
that you know what you never hear
you never hear oh remember [ __ ] the
live action 101
even the dumb girls on facebook aren't
talking about
the animated one yeah no one's talking
about that any disney like live action
stuff
[ __ ] stinks it always has
i think it's because when i was little
um
i was really enamored
with fairy tales and even the darkest
weirdest ones i love fairy tales and i
also
grew up on because i'm so old on things
like
bambi and snow white
and they just were again it was about
basically a bad um
the the children
go to the dark place and then they're
rescued right
and um i noticed that as
the years went on that you have to
remove the mother
basically to have anything happen to the
children
you can have a clueless father you can
have a dick
for pete davidson you had to remove the
father but okay
is this the plot to a movie or are these
just notes that you wrote down during
hollywood's uh
plan on what to do to actual children
well if we remove the mother from the
home we get her in the workplace and
then
uh create a broken one-parent home and
then we can
all of these kids [ __ ] and they went god
damn it goldman it's genius